foreign
is in Los Angeles hi Lynn welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
I am I'm 59
um on the 10th I'll be 59 and a half
and I have a tsp that has a little over
two hundred thousand dollars in it plus
an IRA that has I mean a Ross that has
10 000 in it and about five in my
savings
I want to pay off like my car and a few
other small bills and I'm wondering if
this is the time for me to take out from
my tsp or should I wait what's the total
debt
the total debt on my car is 21
000 and I have uh personal loan for 7
000 and credit cards probably about
1500.
okay so 30k and in order to get that
you're going to need to pull out 45.
so you're gonna have 150k left
okay
then if you go borrow again
kind of screwed this up didn't you
right so part of this formula is never
again
next time you want a car
you pay cash for it or you don't buy it
okay next time you want a dot dot dot
whatever the crud you spent this money
on
you because you keep doing this you're
gonna have no tsp left right
right so the problem is pay all this off
with no pain without feeling the pain of
the stupid decisions that got you here
and then you go back because you don't
change your habits this would be really
bad advice if you are if you can raise
your right hand and swear to yourself
I'm never doing this again then it does
make sense is this logical
yes hey Lynn why can't we just keep
working and pay off this debt
we can do that as well um I retired in
2020 from the post office okay but I I
am now a part-time preschool teacher
okay
um so but I I'm also a caregiver for my
dad so my work schedule is kind of you
know we wonky depending on his health
are you married
yes what's your husband Mike
my husband is on temporary disability so
he brings in about 2 500 a month and
what is his nest egg
he doesn't have one okay so this is your
whole house alternistic
correct
and he keeps wanting me to pull it out
and put it in the bank no but no I I
know that this is that yeah don't do
that don't do that one
um
what's uh what's your mortgage
I don't have a mortgage we rent and our
rent is 1800 a month
I want to buy a home
but I don't think I'm in a position
right now to do that to myself yeah
okay well I think the two of you
combining your efforts and you as you're
able to not to Jade's Point go back to
earning an income uh and the more
substantial income better because
um
uh yes you're debt free when we do this
but debt free is supposed to lead you
then to the ability to build wealth
and if you don't take all these payments
you used to pay
by getting rid of that and any and a
good income and you use it to build
wealth and good Investments if I thought
you could double or triple Your Nest Egg
by the time you're 70 uh because you got
rid of this debt I'd be a whole lot more
excited about it that's what I'm
thinking about for your sake
does you see what I'm doing
yes so getting out of debt is one thing
but getting out of debt so that it's so
that so that I can be more generous so
that I can invest more so that I've got
more freedom that there's a it the the
debt for the debt free part is just a is
just a it's a an exit ramp we take to
get off and go do something better yeah
I'm wondering and I might be wrong I
feel like she retired a little too early
or are you are you required to go out at
a certain point when you work for a
government job no you're not not the
post office but anyway but yeah but it's
too late she's gone so she can't go back
I just I but I would look at what I can
do for my second career yeah because
you're young you got a lot of time left
and
um I I would you know she's got a
caretaking with her father issue and uh
and her husband's on disability so I
don't know what all is going on there
but but I'm gonna uh do some things to
really and preschool doesn't sound
preschool teacher doesn't sound like a
high-paying job to me I could be wrong
well she's part-time doing it too so I
wonder if there's there is there is
something that she can do to earn more
money there's always and there certainly
is over the next three or four or five
years that's right yeah so let's just
keep that going and try to figure out
what we can do there